[Musique]
et aussi sexy garde je pouvais pas je
voulais la prendre avec le thé aussi
sexy que ça alors mademoiselle
chimpanzés enfin pas tant que puissant
ça rien à voir depuis que le risque
alors mademoiselle le chimpanzé
non mais non ça ne sera pas long que la
puissance rien à voir ah non non tu n'as
que comme disait un grand homme
baby baby baby love et ce ne sont pas
des qualités que j'apprécie c'est un et
ce ne sont pas des qualités que
j'apprécie c'est d'une femme up [ __ ]
vous avez fait quand même du bsc eu que
sega c'est un truc c'est petit tissu
bienvenue à marc citti m le maire
monsieur père est femme il porte à faux
un panneau oh je crois que j'ai chopé
une db je parlais en présence de mon
médecin
qu est ce qui se rapproche pour vous le
plus d'un enfant serait clochard
[Musique]
accrocheur
voilà voilà voilà ce que les demoiselles
aujourd'hui c'est une journée très très
importante pour moi même primordial par
rapport à toutes les autres jours par
rapport à toutes les autres pour refaire
parce que je les ai pas lues au bon
endroit ça l'aurait bien sûr ils ont
tout le truc nouvelle rivale valérie
savard elle pleure elle pleurait elle
rigole faut la gifle est positif
moi je pensais plutôt à des êtres
humains des gens des personnes en
situation de handicap
non non non non alors là vraiment
surtout peuvent à chaque fois on dit bon
ils sont où les handicapés
bah ils sont en bas oh là là faut les
monter à la main bah oui on n'a pas le
choix
vous est il sous les handicapés ah bah
ils sont en bas oh là là on pompe en
panne je te prends pas en tentant pas
papa papa papa c'est une perceuse
oui et moi je suis quoi un groupe de
rock
non
et quelle heure il est là bas et 19
ohlala ils sont en bas aulas lors et
qu'est ce qu'ils foutent pas faut les
monter les montées dans quoi le le
monte-charge
oh là là une voiture va vous conduire
jusqu'à votre rendez-vous les autres
pour entrer à la ville un arbre ces prix
la paire de joyeux rien tu es belle moi
j'ai décidé d'emmener valérie dans un
restaurant plongé alors j'ai décidé
d'emmener valérie dans un restaurant
plomb excellente idée
alors pourquoi excellente idée
c'est moi coderre monsieur monsieur
trouvé ça drôle
je suis pas trop fan rencontreront tous
par la trompe et ludovic marque
personnelle fils de personnes ici je
vais vous demander de recul et je perds
une femme
bon
je gagne anne mais franchement regardez
ce que je l'aide de la merde non
regardez la mine belle robe bar daurade
j'étais trop loin
tu vas me baisser son pantalon
j'ai foutu fait c'est que je te foute
out devant tout le monde n'est pas tombé
d'accord je voulais acheter un bel
iphone et baroque qui s'écrit la changer
les couches
quand tu étais je trop tôt aya des
clochards venu en passe de l'autre côté
et non comme on dit a encore des
cultures marines aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
[Musique]
je vois qu'il nous reste 10 minutes vous
voulez fine et voulait faire le pitre
non je vais rentrer d'accord ouais
écoutez moi bien si vous êtes réunis ici
écoutez moi bien si vous êtes très unis
n'ont pas réussi à me dire ça si vous
êtes réunis ce matin c'est que l'heure
est grave
quelqu'un nous a caché quelque chose est
cassé du tamagotchi coeur
[Rires]
[Musique]
si j'adore ça le ta main c'est mon
anniversaire aussi non alexandra vous
mentez alors à tanger un cadeau pour toi
non alexandra vous mentez pardon c'est
mon anniversaire aussi non alexandra
vous mentez la pro a
ok bah vu de fer l'or parce que ça va
que moi ce que je préfère chez un homme
c'est quand il dégaine c'est une cata je
pars donc non les finissiez pas de
retenir
il n'y a pas de place pour deux shérifs
émules d'accord alors c'est pas une
ville c'est un lieu dit de la commune
eux comme le tchad le fait ou non du
clos des moines communes de west rock
park non montceau les mines
[Rires]
c'est nul
ok alors juste un truc tu ne parles pas
comme ça le monde d'accord
si ce super respect d'accord je reste en
revanche l'as roma se présente quelques
amis dont josé était un poison dallas
[Rires]
aleri bien que tu sois sapé comme une
gitane valérie bien que tu sois billets
comme une personne qui vend des
bénévoles
j'ai décidé de te donner ce biais à la
télé paraît-il qui sont obligés de
régler les contrastes pour ne pas avoir
des problèmes de vue
je pars dombasle leur visa mojito que
ses passes au old el paso
non non jose nuno josé non c'est bueno
les folles c'est la balance est quoi la
deuxième l'a aussi en europe et un je
plaisante
si moi je plaisante pas présent bon
explorer tout ça on en gère on va au
bout
excellent